[ __ ]
do you remember me your mom's name is
Sara he used to wear newspapers in your
shoes you're a wanted man I don't do
that anymore
well the people who think you did are
coming right now they're not planning on
taking you alive
captain while a great many people see
you as a hero there are some who'd
prefer the word vigilante they've
operated with unlimited power and no
supervision that's something the world
can no longer tolerate
I know how much Bucky means you stay out
of this one please
you only make this worse you saying
you'll arrest me
big consequences captain you seem a
little defensive
boss been a long day if you can't accept
limitations we're no better new bad guys
that's not the last
so simply want to punch you in your
perfect teeth
I just want to make sure we consider all
our options
just people that shoot at you usually
wind up shooting at me too
know what's about to happen
do you really want to punch your way out
of this
what do we do we fight
sorry Tommy you know I wouldn't do this
if I had any other choice but he's my
friend
so was I
hey youtubers it's Charlie so we got the
full Captain America Civil War teaser
trailer so let's break it down this is
gonna be so awesome biggest thing right
away first look at Black Panther in his
vibranium weave suit he's gonna be so
badass I know it looks like he's
fighting Bucky in this but he might be
one of those characters that switches
Allegiance cuz he's kind of a third
party in this he's not from the United
States and obviously war machine here
always gonna side with Iron Man no
matter what always gonna side with Tony
he's a military man through and through
but it looks like he gets a new suit -
not enough to keep him from getting his
ass kicked
my other favorite moment from the
trailer is cap and Bucky double teaming
Iron Man take take from that what you
will I'm sure tumbler is gonna have fun
with that but don't be surprised that
there's no spider-man in the trailer
they're keeping that such a special
thing that we probably won't see him
till the actual movie maybe at the
earliest it'll be like a vision thing
and they save it for the third trailer
there's usually like three big trailers
after the teaser we also see general
Thunderbolt Ross not expecting Red Hulk
anytime soon maybe the next time we get
a solo Hulk film depending on how the
rights work out in Mark Ruffalo by the
way was actually supposed to be in
Captain America Civil War but they just
stuffed it with so many characters that
they felt like there wasn't room for him
so they pushed him to thor ragnarok
Scarlet Witch also wearing her new
costume vision is in the movie -
hopefully we'll see some conflict
between those two characters they're
really the big villain early on is gonna
be crossbones obviously Daniel Bruhl is
rumored to be Baron Zemo so he'd be a
much bigger villain hopefully he'll
surface later in the movie but for the
most part the heroes will be their own
villains that's the biggest conflict of
the movie if you have read Marvel's
comic book Civil War this movie actually
used to not look anything like it but it
got closer and closer then when they got
spider-man it kind of pushed it over the
edge so you can think of this as being
almost exactly like comic-book Civil War
- a few characters that they don't own
the things you guys should be really
losing your minds about though are a cap
and Bucky double teaming iron man who's
actually gonna have another new suit cap
is wearing his scale armor it looks kind
of like a cross between his age of
Ultron armor in his scale armor from the
comics just a little bit more badass the
New Avengers team were actually inside
the Avengers facility here at the new
facility we saw at the end of age of
Ultron ant-man doesn't show up right
away he doesn't show up till after this
scene here and remember this appeared
during the post-credits scene in ant-man
if he didn't know Martin Freeman is also
in the movie Sherlock is all over the
Marvel versus the Doctor Strange
Benedict Cumberbatch but he is playing a
gov
main character who's kind of a liaison
to superheroes so I'm really curious to
see like what the political situation is
with Wakanda coming into the universe in
their vibranium resources because Black
Panther is actually one of the richest
people on the planet because vibranium
is so precious and adding that into the
mix Tony Stark's experience with vision
is probably gonna put vibranium on his
radar - what would you do with vibranium
if you're Tony Stark probably built a
lot of new suits because this is civil
war though it is definitely not going to
end well so I don't think that
everyone's gonna be shaking hands so I
don't know if Tony Stark is gonna get a
vibranium suit or not in black panther
seems like he's gonna be team cap for
most of the movie so I don't think he'd
be inclined to give it up either most
you're probably asking though like what
sets this off why is everyone after
Bucky well probably because information
gets out about all the shady stuff that
he did when he was part of Hydra he was
an assassin for a long time he goes all
the way back to Kennedy so wouldn't the
US government go after the person that
they found out killed one of their US
presidents but here's a really big
easter egg Bucky in the comics killed
Iron Man's parents so I don't know if
they're gonna do that in the movie verse
but I feel like that'd be one more
reason for Captain America to fight with
Iron Man to save his friend like you
killed my parents
oh that's it you are done for the other
big part of the conversation is Inhumans
because they're developing them on
agents of shield but in say like the
daredevil Netflix universe they've been
referring to them as gifted people so
I'm not expecting them to use the word
Inhumans and Captain America Civil War
so I think they'll call them gifted or
people with powers just like the Jessica
Jones series did but for the most part
is the government being afraid of people
with powers in general whether they're
good or bad
Inhumans or they got their powers in
some Stanly type of accident so that's
what brings general Thunderbolt Ross
into the mix and he's kind of the
figurehead for the government in this
movie not a big fan of superheroes let
me know in the comments below that what
did you guys favorite moment from this
trailer in I'm actually I'm gonna go
ahead and do a giveaway all you have to
do to enter is be subscriber and leave a
comment on this video why don't we see
IMAX movie gift certificates for two
people that ends up being like a $50
value so all you have to do to enter
that is be subscriber and leave a
comment on this video I'll do a Q&A
video in a day or two it'll announce the
winner whenever I post that so just for
reference I think they're going to be
posting another trailer in a month or so
like when we get closer to Star Wars
they might post a longer version of the
trailer that'll give you a better idea
of who's
what team but I've already done a video
they've already been a lot of rumors
about that so I'll put a link for that
in the description
everybody proceed to freak out it is
going to be so awesome this December
there's so much stuff coming we have a
new Batman vs Superman there's a
Deadpool trailer coming there's x-men
apocalypse and and of course Star Wars
is coming out so while you guys wait for
everything to post you can click here
for all my Captain America Civil War
videos and you can click here for all
the Star Wars trailer videos I've been
posting and don't forget daredevil
season 2 is gonna drop just before
Captain America Civil War is coming so
by your Punisher t-shirts it's gonna be
so awesome thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight
you